global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight from Weldon
Saskatchewan
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news after a
Manhunt that has loomed over this
province since Sunday multiple sources
now tell Global News the murder suspect
miles Sanderson who was apprehended this
afternoon has died they believe as a
result of self-inflicted injuries he had
evaded arrest for days but was spotted
this afternoon in a stolen vehicle RCMP
arrested him on a highway near roster
and Saskatchewan just over an hour's
drive from where we are here in weld in
Saskatchewan and I can tell you when
news of that Manhunt ending broke there
was huge relief here Heather urich's
West is near the site of the arrests
along a highway Heather
Donna we are just south of the community
of Ross turn Saskatchewan and you can
see behind me a huge police presence on
this highway and you can also see uh in
the ditch just across the uh the highway
here a 2010 white Chevy Avalanche that
was the stolen vehicle that Miles
Sanderson was driving when he was taken
into custody at about 3 30 this
afternoon now the pursuit began uh
shortly after two o'clock there was a
report that Miles was driving that
stolen vehicle fleeing the community of
iwaka which is about half an hour away
from here he was armed with a knife an
emergency alert went out shortly before
three o'clock warning people that he had
been cited and of course that Pursuit
came here it ended on this highway or we
were told that RCMP employed something
called a pit maneuver where they
actually hit rammed his vehicle the
vehicle spun out they were able to take
him into custody he was taken by
ambulance and as you mentioned multiple
sources now confirming to Global News
that uh miles Sanderson has since died
of his injuries and we are told that
those injuries are believed to be
self-inflicted so after a three day Long
Prairie wide Manhunt that had so many
communities on edge it has come to an
end the police remain here on scene I'm
sure that there is more investigative
work to do but once again miles
Sanderson no longer at large was taken
into custody and multiple sources
confirming to Global News that he has
since died Donna
all right Heather urich's West thank you
we'll check back in with you in just a
few minutes a global Saskatoon reporter
Tanner chubby happened to be on the
highway near roster and when the arrest
of this man took place and he saw it all
go down
we're about halfway between Hague and
roster and it was a hectic scene when we
arrived looking in the ditch going
towards Saskatoon there was a white
truck with airbags pop police vehicles
surrounding it and dozens of police
officers crowding the area we saw a
individual get lifted into the ambulance
and was escorted back towards Saskatoon
with two vehicles one marked and one
unmarked right now traffic is backed up
it is being directed I should say
traffic heading towards Saskatoon is
being redirected to a grid road to the
side right now as police wait for Major
Crimes units to come out here and
provide more details
all right that's a global saskatoon's
Tanner chubby Mike Armstrong is outside
RCMP headquarters in Regina tonight Mike
what more have you learned about the
operation to capture this man
well we should be learning a great deal
more in about an hour the commanding
officer has just arrived here
um the commanding officer of the RCMP
Saskatchewan a press conference has been
called for 7 30 p.m local time they're
going to be a lot of questions first how
was Sanderson spotted in a stolen
vehicle this afternoon what happened
there then the arrest itself how was
Sanderson taken down Global News sources
have said police would have rammed him
from behind but there will also be
questions about Sanderson in custody how
was he treated how was he perhaps left
alone meantime we are learning more also
about sanderson's uh past history Global
News has obtained and reviewed more
court documents they paint a a very
clear portrait of a man who is very
often in trouble with the law and with a
very violent streak his past charges
range from car theft and impaired
driving to aggravated assault and the
attempted murder of his father-in-law
Earl Earl Burns was one of the victims
in Sunday's attack now despite that
history the parole board Grand into the
Sanderson a statutory release on his
most recent sentence letting him out
early the federal Public Safety Minister
now says the parole board will conduct a
review of that decision because
something very clearly went wrong Donna
Nick Armstrong outside RCMP headquarters
in Regina thanks well we all got an
alert from the police about the arrest
on our phones and in this little village
of Weldon where one of the victims was
killed there was immediate relief people
here feared the suspect might come back
I spoke with two residents here just
after that arrest
I just got the news attack thing they
caught him I'm glad they did yeah now we
can get the grief process going for both
communities
now I'll get a decent sleep tonight it's
still gonna be a healing process for
sure
um
yeah Wes was just a super sweet guy and
uh
it's I'm sorry it's just it's a horrible
thing now that we have to put the pieces
back together but yeah yeah but at least
you can rest easy yes we can breathe and
move on yes exactly
we got the first detailed information
today about those who were killed in the
stabbings on the James Smith Cree Nation
who they were and how they're being
remembered the youngest was 23 years old
the eldest 78 years old among them were
mothers and fathers a community first
responder and a veteran why is the
question everyone is asking
how can some somebody do this to women
and children
words can't express
the pain that we're feeling
trying to piece it all together
that's mark arkand his sister and his
nephew are among the victims he and
other family members of those who were
killed spoke publicly for the first time
today Heather urich's West was there
Heather
such emotion such pain in their voices
yeah I mean he spoke for more than an
hour giving us all just an emotionally
crushing glimpse into what his family
has been through uh since Sunday morning
when they lost two beloved family
members uh the family matriarch Bonnie
good voice Burns and her 28 year old son
Gregory affectionately known by his
nickname Jonesy
theirs was a family often full of
laughter Bonnie and her husband Brian
known to everyone by his nickname buggy
built a loving home for their four Sons
it's why this tragedy is so impossible
to understand
we've shed a lot of Tears in the last
couple days
when I think about my sister and
our nephew
our son
they were in their house
place where we all go to sleep at night
thinking we'll be safe
the family is still trying to piece
together exactly what happened but they
believe Bonnie mother to four sons and
two foster children died trying to
protect her kids she and her oldest son
were found dead outside their home
alongside Gloria burns the first
responder who rushed to the house trying
to help she was protecting her son
she was protecting these three little
boys
this is why she's a hero
our canned was supported during his
emotional remarks by many more members
of the family including Bonnie's husband
with the loss of his son father buggy
Burns still too hurt to speak publicly
the couple's three youngest sons were
here too boys Grayson dason and Mason
were all home Sunday morning when the
attack happened one of the boys was
stabbed and spent a night in hospital
left now with a hurt and loss that will
take much longer to heal
these two young boys
woke up the screening
not being not being able to help
a GoFundMe has been set up for Bonnie's
surviving children arcan says his sister
would have wanted to ensure her foster
kids were cared for too
but Gregory her oldest boy could not be
saved his life over at only 28. Gregory
leaves behind two children of his own
with another child on the way a father
son and brother known affectionately by
his nickname
moments of laughter are helping the
family cope right now happy memories
help hold back the anger and pain our
can revealing How Deeply the trauma has
tested him
I've been sober for 22 years of my life
that day I wanted to turn to alcohol
I wanted to turn to it so bad
that I could taste it
instead he says he's turning to love for
his family and the memory of his nephew
and sister honoring them in the best way
he can
we're hurting
we're broken but we're not defeated
now this morning the Saskatchewan
coroner service and the RCMP released
pictures and names of the victims along
with Bonnie goodwise Burns and her son
Gregory there were four other members of
the Burns family who died including 66
year old Earl 61 year old Lydia Gloria
46 year old Carol and 23 year old Thomas
Lana and Christian head aged 49 and 54
were also killed along with 49 year old
Robert Sanderson all of the James Cree
Nation and 78 year old Wes Peterson of
Weldon and I will mention that you know
to get to this scene you have to go from
Saskatoon back to the James Cree James
Smith Cree Nation and um that we heard
from that family earlier in Saskatoon so
that family was making their way down
this highway when the alert came news
came that that Miles Sanderson was
caught and taken into custody the family
stopped here just to see where it
happened telling us that it brought them
a little bit of closure so that they can
now focus on their grief and focus on
looking forward to Healing Donna
all right Heather York's West on the
highway near roster and Saskatchewan
thanks
so many people are wondering what they
can do to support the victims their
families and the communities affected by
these terrible crimes one GoFundMe
campaign organized by a former MP
quickly surpassed its goal of one
hundred thousand dollars the James Smith
Cree Nation now says it's grateful to
all the donors but asks that no one else
contribute and it says it hasn't
endorsed any other crowdfunding
campaigns there are others providing
practical support including a woman I
met in Prince Albert who has deep ties
to the families of the dead and injured
James Smith is my community Dawn Robbins
is executive director of a non-profit
Community Center in Prince Albert many
of her relatives live on the James Smith
Cree Nation my families are interrelated
I
I really had a hard time sitting at home
over the weekend and and having all
these you know emergency things pop up
everywhere so she got to work just
whatever we can provide soliciting
donations not cash and shopping for food
and supplies three truckloads have
already been sent to James Smith but Don
this is personal for you because of all
these interconnections absolutely and
yeah it's hard to go there right now
like that's why I'm trying to keep busy
and and support rather than you know
dwell in and break down instead she's
delivering practical support Guided by
what the community needs we need Meats
we need soups we need sanitizer we need
plates cups bowls they've even asked for
Wild game the center's slogan is
together we can do so much and that's
what she's focused on right now we're
just in different stages of grieving
whether it be anger whether it be
sadness whether it be shock and and I
think that's where I'm just kind of
coming out of but
I have to do what I have to do to cope
and this is my coping mechanism is to
help
if you'd like to donate food and other
items Dawn told me you can contact the
Bernice saees Center in Prince Albert
Saskatchewan well as the days of the
events of the last few days in
Saskatchewan have shown communication is
vital and after the Nationwide Rogers
outage this summer the government is now
promising action to ensure 9-1-1 and
other communication links don't go down
as David Akin reports ottawa's vowing
more will be done to improve the
reliability of the country's Wireless
and internet networks
after millions of Roger's customer went
through the outage on July the 8th the
federal government gave all of the
country's major Telecom firms 60 days to
figure out how to back each other up to
provide emergency service the
telecommunication companies complied
with our requests to take meaningful
actions to increase and improve Network
reliability and our country as we
requested the agreement they've reached
runs 40 pages and has the signatures of
the CEOs of 13 companies including Bell
Rogers Shaw Telus and smaller providers
like sastel and Explore Net going
forward should one of these providers be
faced with a major outage the other
companies commit to providing the
support and the assistance they each
agree that if one network goes down
others will help maintain 9-1-1 service
emergency roaming services and maintain
Bank networks businesses need to process
transactions critics though remain
unimpressed absolute incredible nonsense
and I'm very disappointed because it's
very lackluster with the lack of
enforcement and fines and penalties for
these companies that have a virtual
monopoly is almost meaningless and who
will pay for all this well not the
customer champagne says that like a hawk
uh but uh my expectation is that They
Carried a cosmic and that's not the end
of the story champagne says the crtc
will soon have new rules and the Trudeau
government May soon have new regulations
to force telecoms to provide more
reliable service and finally the
government plans to build out what it's
calling the public safety Broadband
Network it will be the ultimate batstop
should private networks fail in an
emergency Donna
David Akin in Vancouver thanks coming up
the bank of Canada's key interest rate
keeps climbing
returning to our top story now multiple
sources tell Global News the murder
suspect The Wanted Man miles Sanderson
has died he was arrested earlier this
afternoon noon near roster and
Saskatchewan number of officers took
Sanderson into custody alongside the
highway you can see some of the vehicles
in the ditch there this means the public
safety alert that is loomed over this
province for several days now has been
canceled
turning now to the economy it wasn't
unexpected but today's Bank of Canada
interest rate hike is still on welcome
news for hundreds of thousands of
Canadians the key interest rate is now
3.25 percent that's up 75 basis points
this is the fifth increase since the
Central Bank began lifting rates from
Rock Bottom levels in March Canada's
interest rate is now the highest it's
been since 2008.
we are back from Saskatchewan in just a
moment
welcome back to weld in Saskatchewan
this is a community in mourning as is
the James Smith Cree Nation it's hard
for people to talk about what happened
but today family members of some of the
victims did they did it to honor their
loved ones Mark Arcon says his sister
and nephew died trying to save the rest
of their family and he calls them Heroes
I would never wish this on anyone
people don't realize maybe they have a
good idea but they don't realize the
pain the trauma the hurt
and when I think about my sister and
our nephew
our son
they were in their house
a place where we all go to sleep at
night thinking we'll be safe
how can some somebody do this to women
in children
words can't express
the pain that we're feeling
it's probably a natural feeling for all
of us
to feel anger
that was my that was my first initial
thought
and it's okay to feel those feelings
but those feelings aren't going to solve
anything
and when I think about what the future
looks like
my sister our family members
they'd want us to move on
they'd want us to heal
but to never forget
and to carry love in your hearts
carry compassion
to be United
to think of other people
we've shed a lot of Tears in the last
couple days
but at the end of the day
we loved our sister
Brian's wife
Chuck's daughter her niece
our nephew
her grandson
because they loved us too
that's what we want people to remember
as difficult as it is to
nacho emotion
we're hurting
we're broken
but we're not defeated
nothing can remove the pain but there is
help for some of those people who want
to reach out you can call the hope for
wellness helpline the number is
1-855-242-3310 you can also call crisis
Services Canada at
1-833-456-4566 we're back from
Saskatchewan in a moment
welcome back to Saskatchewan we're going
to go back to our top story multiple
sources tell global news that Miles
Sanderson the man wanted after multiple
stabbings in this province has now died
Heather urich's West is with us again
from near the site of where Sanderson
was arrested this afternoon Heather
yeah Donna this brings to an end just an
exhaustive police effort the last few
days to bring this suspect into custody
there's still a heavy heavy police
presence along this highway just north
of Saskatoon south of roster where we
know that Miles Sanderson was taken into
custody at 3 30 and then as you
mentioned we have learned that since
then he has has died this brings the the
total number of dead in this very very
tragic event to 12 11 of them from the
James Smith Cree Nation and of course
one from Wells and Saskatchewan so I
mean I'm hearing very very heavy hearts
some some relief from some communities
but I'm also hearing that on the the
James Smith cremation tonight you know
people are feeling really emotionally
raw with this news that the Manhunt is
over but of course their grieving
continues
Heather do we know anything about the
circumstances of his deaths during or
after that arrest
yeah a lot of questions and we know that
the RCMP will be having a press
conference shortly but we do uh we have
learned that it is believed that his
injuries were self-inflicted and that he
was taken from the scene in an ambulance
so obviously more questions will need to
be answered we're hoping to get those
questions later tonight Donna
all right Heather urich's Wes near
roster in Saskatchewan tonight thank you
that is global national for this
Wednesday from Saskatchewan I am Donna
Friesen thanks for watching we'll see
you back here tomorrow bye-bye
thank you